[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn here even our greatest
scientists don't understand the youtube
algorithm
but for some reason it seems to like it
when you guys hit the like button
so if you appreciate my content click
like so that youtube actually remembers
to notify people when i upload
it has been often said that nature is
cruel
all life on earth is believed to have
evolved from the same single-celled
organism
over the course of 3.5 billion years
those single cells diversified
multiplied
became multiple celled organisms
developed organs bones and limbs
life eventually filled every niche on
the planet
each species learning to survive in its
own way
while constantly being tested by mother
nature
but the cruelest fact about life has
always been
that in order to survive it must feed
upon itself
and compete against itself life consumes
life
and there are many ways of doing it a
butcher bird is a type of bird found
mostly in
african and eurasian countries it is a
type of bird known as a shrike
once a strike captures its prey it
impales the body upon
sharp thorns or spikes this allows the
strike
to bit by bit tear the flesh from the
creature it has captured
eating it in small chunks these birds
are also known to be territorial
they defended their acclaimed areas
against rivals
the idea of a strike has been used in
fiction multiple times
but dan simmons is hyperion in my
opinion
makes the most interesting use of the
attributes of the strike bird
within a fictional creature i've made
several videos discussing the hyperion
cantos
you can find those videos in a playlist
linked in the description
the hyperion cantos is an epic science
fiction series following in the
footsteps of the work of isaac asimov
frank herbert and jack vance in the
hyperion canters
mankind forms an interstellar hegemony
after earth was destroyed
and an experiment gone wrong the
hegemony would eventually connect at
least
200 worlds fat line connections allowed
communication between worlds
while what was called forecaster
technology allowed for instantaneous
travel between connected planets
there were many humans who lived outside
of the influence of the hegemony
such as the ousters and many inhabited
worlds
not connected by farcaster or fatline
such worlds were known as outback worlds
the world hyperion is of course an
outback planet
the world is earth-like and contains
three continents
equus aquila and ursus
as well as a single small moon the sun
of hyperion was said to shine brighter
than the sun of earth
though it was smaller in mass hyperion
was also known to be one of the nine
labyrinthine worlds
but we will talk more about that in
another video
other than this hyperion had two other
things that made it an astounding world
the time tombs structures of unknown
origins
which emitted anti-entropic fields the
tomb seemed to be moving backwards in
time
and of course the creature sometimes
called the lord of pain
the shrike it was vaguely man-shaped
but in no way human it stood at least
three meters tall
even when it was at rest the silvered
surface of the thing
seemed to shift and flow like mercury
suspended in mid
air the reddish glow from the crosses
set into the tunnel walls reflected from
sharp surfaces and glinted on the curved
metal blades
protruding from the thing's forehead
four wrist
oddly jointed elbows knees armored back
and thorax i've covered the strike and
its incredible abilities
already in this video here
the strike's appearance itself is
terrifying enough
until you find out what it actually does
once it decides to make you
its victim like the shrike butcher birds
i mentioned in the beginning of this
video
the hyperion strike also impales its
prey upon spikes
using the glistening metal thorns of its
tree of pain
shimmering mirage-like a tree of steel
thorns appeared out of the haze and a
sudden dust storm of ochre sand
the thing seemed to fill the valley
rising at least 200 meters to the
heights of the cliffs
branches shifted dissolved and reformed
like
the elements of a poorly tuned hologram
sunlight danced on five meter long
thorns
corpses of ouster men and women all
naked were impaled on at least a score
of these
thorns other branches held other bodies
not all were human the final tree
or the tree of pain is a key part of the
strike legend
among those who worshiped him as the
lord of pain
when the strike chose not to completely
destroy its victims outright
he brought them to this tree the tree
itself does not truly exist as a
physical tree
it is eventually revealed to be an ultra
advanced simulation
the victims he chose to impale were
brought to his strike palace
and neurally plugged into his simulation
the pain he put them through was
exquisite
they eternally suffer the torment of the
impaled
just as fully as if they were real only
without the eventual release of death
there were endless victims impaled upon
the tree of pain
the strengths motivations are largely
mysterious
its power seems almost god like
and its cruelty is unmatched perhaps one
of the most terrifying things about the
creature
is its seeming indifference it does not
seem to feel
pain or fear or happiness or empathy
it merely acts to work towards its
strange goal
more about the strikes motivations are
eventually revealed in the series
but the essential horror of the strike
arrives from the fact
that for most of the time we have no
idea
why it does what it does or wants what
it wants
only that it is capable of great and
terrifying things
for more on hyperion check out the
hyperion playlist found on my channel
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
science fiction lore